this is the chapter of the book that
deals with the rise of Islam and
medieval Islamic society
you would think that that would be the
easiest chapter for a person to write if
that person happened to be a specialist
on medieval Islam because you'd already
know everything it turned out it was not
an easy chapter to write and now that I
look back on it and think about things I
want to say about it
I really have great misgivings about
what I wrote in the chapter in some
measure
I felt coerced in small things for
example publisher saying to the FIR
after the first draft you didn't mention
the five pillars of Islam I thought it's
because I don't think the five pillars
of Islam are particularly interesting
and even though they show up in a few
hadith of the Prophet they're really not
coequal you know pilgrimage and paying
alms and prayer and fasting and the
profession of faith in God and His
Messenger when they're presented as five
pillars you think well here is a
structure that was supported by these
five co-equal things and they're by no
means coequal neither in their substance
nor in their continuity over time so
that the importance of these different
things changes over time and I felt that
if I put in a paragraph about the five
pillars of Islam which I eventually felt
forced to do that I would be
contributing to the notion of a
homogenous ation of a bosom experienced
over historical time which I am opposed
to then there was
the question of what readers
expectations were for me to write about
the Tong dynasty or the Kiev and Russia
where I'm not a specialist I can go take
several books and I'll read them fold
them together add a little bit of fairy
dust and come up with my own truncated
narrative of what they say but
ultimately I'm not responsible for what
they say because I don't know what I'm
talking about and it's it's a great
relief you you try and pick the best
books to put together but the problem is
that when when you are when you are an
authority as I fancy I am in this area
you can't do that and yet you know how
other people in your field handle the
history and you don't want to be such an
outlier that that it doesn't sound like
Islamic history at one point there was a
thing was after the third edition of the
second edition one of the reviewers a
user I think in a small College in
California wrote and said he thought the
entire chapter should be scrapped
because the new scholarly view
maintained that Muhammad never existed
that the Quran was composed by a a
gaggle of rabbis in Iraq two hundred
years after the alleged date of
Muhammad's life and that it arose as a
Jewish heresy and had blah blah blah
well now that's a completely different
view of Islam and it is one that has
some distinguished if profoundly
mistaken scholars
who who support it and I could I could
see that someone who who is not a
specialist might say oh well maybe I
should look into it and maybe I should
lean in that direction so I leaned in
that direction for about one paragraph
just to acknowledge that there was this
DBM view out there and I thought that's
fine you had a basic story of rise of
Islam and spread to the Caliphate and of
course they had the usual things you
know put in more about women putting
more about Spain everyone thinks Spain
is cool but the basic narrative is sort
of a white bread narrative now I've come
to think that it's deeply mistaken and I
don't know what to do about it
I don't know whether to write it the way
I think it happened in which case the
sixth edition would would depart
dramatically from both from the first
five editions and from every other world
history textbook or whether to sort of
sneak subversive thoughts in sort of
between paragraphs and imply that there
might be a different way of telling the
story now the nice thing about having a
chance to to lecture is that I can give
you the revised version and then you can
compare it to to the written version the
revised version really arises to to some
extent as I as I look at it an
afterthought having finally come up with
it on some problems that were very
difficult to answer about what happened
in the early the first two or three
centuries of Islam what we believe from
the Chronicles and from the way the
Chronicles have
digested by modern historians I say what
we believe because all the chronicles
written at least two three four hundred
years after these events so they are in
large part here say they don't
for the most part quote documents they
quote oral histories that are in many
cases fundamentally unbelievable but
what that story says is that the Prophet
died in 632 or 630 I he was followed by
a series of four caliphs the from 636 32
for Emma Becker from 632 to 642 for Omar
642 to 654 for earth man and then you
have a civil war after the death of auth
man
because off man was assassinated and
that is called the first the first fitna
this all-purpose word in Arabic that
covers disorders in the the body social
all the way from a civil war down to a
family dispute it's really quite
interesting that you can have a single
word that covers disorders at every
level of aggregation the knot wars
there's a separate word for war but
fitna is a disorder in the body social
that does not have a clear analog in
English because in English we tend to
define disorders according to the scale
so in other words a feud would not be
mistaken for a civil war or a argument
without me discussion mistaken for civil
war or an uppity wife would not be
mistaken for a civil war but all these
things can be fitna so you're the first
fitna
after the assassination with man in 654
all of this looked at from several
centuries posterior to the events and
the chronicles that we have and out of
that there arises a two things first a
movement dedicated to both man's
immediate successor Ali given a be
taller
Muhammad's cousin and son-in-law the
husband of his wife ottoman and this is
the this is what yields on shiism the
Shia a word for party and Arabic
literally means the Shia Ali the party
of Ali and all Shiites everywhere at all
times believe that the leadership of the
community spiritually and in many cases
politically rightfully belongs by
rightfully being by divine right to some
descendant of Ali Sunni Islam is by and
large defined as those Muslims who are
not Shiites who believe that somebody
there should be some other way of
finding out who's the leader but it's
and it couldn't be a descendant of Ali
there's nothing to preclude a descendant
of Ali being regarded as the political
leader by by Sonny's the king of Jordan
is a direct descendant of Ali the King
of Morocco is a direct descendent of Ali
yet neither one is a Shiite because it
is not a divinely sanctioned leadership
that that is marked by their role as
king but rather a leadership that comes
about through some you know
sort of some human sublunar device that
you know people have figured out a way
to decide who's the leader where as
along the Shiites its God uh so that's
one thing that comes out of it and then
the opponent of ali founds what is
called the first dynasty in islam these
are the Umayyads the people who come
from the clan of ume and until 750 they
provide the government in the islamic
community the first four caliphs Abu
Bakr Umar Uthman and Ali are later
called the rightfully guided Kahless
Rashi dune they didn't they weren't
called the Rashi dune at the time to
term somebody invented and was used and
the Umayyads who set up their government
in opposition to Ali and Ali gets
assassinated in the process they are
called by the later the chroniclers the
people who introduced Moke into Islam
Mulk meaning kingship which is a
negative term it's mulk as opposed to
the caliphate he laughs on the quality
of being a Calif even though these
omayyad Kings were in fact kaleb's that
was their the title used but later
chroniclers who were hostile to their
memory describe this smoke to them so
I'm not going to pursue this this story
beyond this because it's a it's a
construct that is extremely meaningful
for understanding how the world Muslim
community looks at its and its roots
but it doesn't necessarily jibe with the
with things that may actually have
occurred I'm not saying these things
didn't occur I'm just saying that it's
the question of emphasis interpretation
that is more more questionable for
example everybody agrees that when the
Arabs conquered certain very important
provinces the visiting Empire
specifically Syria Egypt and Tunisia
everybody agrees that retained the the
essentials of the byzantine
administration and they retained the
byzantine currency that is to say they
continued to mint gold dinars the latin
word Denarius and these gold dinars up
until very shortly after the year 700
had a picture on it of the Calif and on
the back they had a you know the genuine
Byzantine one had something like this a
cross on some steps so the Muslims came
up with one and have steps and that
instead they remove the arms of the
Cross then there's a question of what in
the world this was and it shows up
actually in a more specific way in a
silver coin where it is shown as
like this with a couple of ribbons
floating out and it's interpreted that
this was the the spear of Mohammed and
that when he had people when he led
people in prayer to indicate the
direction they should pray he would
thrust the the foot of his spear into
the ground and that was the initial
Qibla the initial indication of the
direction of prayer we don't know
whether this is true or not but I think
it's a good story and this thing does
look sort of like a spear except for
this and the interpretation of that
given the date of the particular coin
this shows is that this occurred after
one of the most zealous advocates of Ali
was executed by the Caliph for raising
Cain in the name of Ali and the way this
would happen was that you know when you
would have the prayer on Friday which is
the noon prayer which is when blessings
are called upon the ruler and the ruler
is named under these Umayyads who
believed in Moke they would call
blessings on the Caliph who lived in
Damascus and then they would call curses
down on Ali and his family and the
cursing of Ali really annoyed the people
who had been close to him and to his
family and so in response they would
pick up stones in from the floor of the
mosque and throw them at the at the
prayer leader now the reason we know
something about this although we may not
really know it but their chronicles
report in such-and-such a year the
mosque was paved and the interpretation
is that they put in paving stones in the
mosque so there weren't any free stones
to pick up to throw the prayer leader
but that meant then you couldn't stick
the end of your spear into the ground
because you didn't have any soft ground
until this by Van interpretation this is
a tripod that is meant to sort of hold
the spear upright
it's a fanciful story it may be true it
may be total yo historians baloney
this is what historians do they make it
up part of the time maybe a little more
than part of the time but but the going
back to the currency thing the coins
that you had in the Byzantine
territories remained the old gold coins
that looked very very similar to the
visiting coins and in the Persian areas
Iraq and Iran the coins were silver and
not gold
they were deer humps they looked and
were the same size as the deer hems of
the solid kings and they have on one
side a portrait of the Sossaman ruler
and the other side they had a
Zoroastrian fire altar with two
attendants now this is this is the new
religion of Islam it's setting up a
state you know we're not talking about
something like 60 years after the major
battles of conquest and they're still
putting out currencies that show images
that appear to be those of the Christian
Byzantines the Zoroastrian sassanids
plus they don't they have a a bimetallic
currency the the gold is not circulate
in the East the silver does not
circulate in the West so you appear to
have a very slow process of wedding
together two very disparate sections of
the of the conquered territory I'm
leaving out space
I'm leaving out sims southern Pakistan
lower Indus Valley it's under water now
anyway so who cares and I'm only going
to talk about the the West as being
Egypt Tunisia Syria greater Syria and
this meaning and the East is being Iraq
and around getting into Central Asia
these are the two big areas they have
they do not have a unified economy they
retain the administrative practices of
the preceding empires of the Byzantines
and the sassanids there's been work done
going into quite some detail
particularly on the Iranian side about
this retention of soft solid Persian
practices Michael Morin II of UCLA has
written a book on the first century
Muslim rule in Iraq you also have very
good work done on Egypt based on early
papyri that show that are in Greek and
sometimes bilingual in Greek and Arabic
showing the the continuation of Greek
ruling practices in Egypt and Syria
primarily in Egypt because we don't have
a pirated Syria
ah and following on what I've lectured
on last week there is what appears I
think now to most historians to be the
near certainty that almost everyone
living in this Empire in those first 72
hundred years was a non-muslim in other
words this Umayyad Caliphate this
rashidun caliphate consisted of a
extraordinary thin veneer of a ruling
establishment and its army spread
geographically over an enormous
territory and ruling over a non Muslim
population
that had its own economy had its own
religious practices had its own
administrative traditions had its own
educational and legal institutions and
of course one of the great questions is
when that happens because it's not the
only time in history that you've had a
thin veneer of the people spread widely
there's question why does it sometimes
change the society and other times it
doesn't so later on we're going to
discover for example that the Mongols
who have an enormous leap our 'fl an
extensive empire that stretches from
from iraq to beijing for hundred years
almost
the Mongols leave very little trace they
don't leave they're just holding much
evidence that they were that they were
there once you get past the period when
they're actually ruling if you take on
the other hand the Germans who come into
the late Roman Empire they transform
Europe and they become the people who
define the culture of the early medieval
period in Europe as I'll be talking
about next week clearly when you go to
the colonial period we're dealing with
tiny numbers of Spaniards and Portuguese
and Dutch and English who have in some
cases powerfully transformative impacts
but they're particularly these days when
we have so much post-colonial theorizing
you can go back to what I've talked
about earlier with with colonization to
what degree did this apparent triumph of
Greek culture pervade by a veneer of
Greek and Macedonian War veterans and
ruling families after Alexander to what
degree was that real what greed that
we penetrate the society now the one
thing that appears to be unquestioned
about the conquest of Islam is that in
the long run everything was changed it
was not an epic phenomenon rather than
disappearing the Arabs who at the time
of the conquests were known almost
exclusively in the Arabian desert and in
the in the desert fringe areas in Iraq
and Syria the Arabic language becomes
adopted all the way from the borders of
Iran across to Morocco so the notion of
what an Arab is changes completely and
the Arabs are seen as the purveyors of a
new culture a new religion in the long
run of the great preponderance of
population converts to this religion and
the culture the society comes to be
defined by the institutional and
intellectual and spiritual particulars
of this new religion so what you deal
with Islam is spectacular success
compared with numerous other historical
examples of extraordinary conquest
followed by indifferent follow-on
effectiveness so why was this lime so
successful probably that you know some
of you will be saying well why am I
talking about Islam as if it were a you
know an improvised explosive device or
something it is Islam is not a thing and
so when I say why is Islam is successful
obviously it's up Islam is not an agent
here it's simply the collectivity of
Muslims you can say well why we're
Muslims successful but then the problem
is if you do it that way then you
realize that the Muslims subdivide and
subject
subdivide into different localized
communities of aggregate in different
ways that have somewhat different
beliefs and it becomes harder and harder
to define exactly what what you mean
about Islam but let me pursue this
business you had a ruling family in
Damascus you had a Shiite movement
opposed to it that never manages to to
come to power or at least rarely
managers come to power so can be sort of
put on the back burner you have a split
economy a split tradition of
administration and of governing language
and you have a population that is
overwhelmingly non-muslim split between
Christians from the tigris-euphrates
westward and Zoroastrians from the
Tigris and Euphrates eastward with Jews
sprinkled in somewhat a clumpy fashion
here and there in both Iran Iraq and
Syria and Egypt and these are your main
groups once you go farther you've got
some pagan outliers in Central Asia and
North Africa you've got some Buddhist
outliers as you move toward India and
Afghanistan but it's primarily Jews
Christians and sir Austrians in 750
there is a change of government the
Umayyad family that has been ruling from
Damascus somehow managed to move from
Damascus without actually seeming to
leave any imprint on the city at all
beyond the main mosque they're
overthrown they're overthrown by a
movement from Iran particularly from
northeastern Iran that has a very strong
has a leadership element
that combines some of the family of
Mohammed particularly from his the
descendants of his uncle al abbas were
called the ambassador's Ali was the
cousin of Muhammad his father was known
as abu talib al abbas is a different as
a brother of a batalov it's a different
uncle so you had members of the family
of a past who may or may not have
thought of themselves as stalking horses
for the family of ali a lot of debate
about that and you had a certain number
of Iranians of somewhat mysterious
character in other words seemingly the
most that the money man behind the
revolt that brings the Ambassador to
power in 750 appears to be the son of a
Buddhist monk from a very powerful
monastery in northern Afghanistan and in
the late 700s the descendants of this
particular the abbot of this Buddhist
monastery become the most powerful
family in the Abbasid Caliphate other
than the families of the chaos
themselves they're known as the Barbican
ultimately of this comes from their
ancestor whose name is given as bar mac
but that is actually from the sanskrit
promote ah meaning an elder of a
buddhist monastery and we've pretty sure
that that this has pinned out that these
were people of a Buddhist background
that's our Austrian so how did the
Buddhist get control of Islam that
doesn't seem quite right
other people who were involved in this
movement were Iranians who appeared to
have had heterodox views of of different
sorts some of them believed in
transmigration of souls were they
Buddhist we don't know there was one in
particular who's considered the central
ringleader of the whole thing who went
by the nom de guerre of ABBA Muslim
always portrayed carrying a hatchet I
have no idea why he's portrayed carrying
a hatchet but he is by the 13th 14th
century you have a long epic poem that's
the saga of Abba Muslim there's no saga
of the ambassador's just about the
Muslim we don't know really who he is he
may have been from his fahan but he may
have been from somewhere else certainly
his name was out not ABBA muscle but
there's no agreement as to what his real
name was he is portrayed as putting the
ambassadors in power and then being
executed by the Caliph in order to keep
him from from exercising the genuine
power that he had achieved so this led
historians particularly at the late 19th
century to say that what happened was
that the Iranians took over Islam there
was a very famous german historian named
Julius Wellhausen who wrote a book
called the Arab Kingdom and it's fall
Kingdom meaning Moke meaning the
Umayyads the story of the Umayyads and
their fall the Arab Kingdom comes to an
end what comes after it the persians
take over this is being written around
the time of bismarck a German
unification the idea of the national
folk becoming the
you know expressed through a United
State and so you had Iranian people who
were very big on Iran particularly
Germans because they saw the Bavarians
saying this is the Iranian take over
from the via feet Arabs and then other
people who are pro Arab saying no this
is no this is still an Arab thing it's
surprising how deep some of these
feelings go I argued with my thesis
advisor again and again and again that
Muslim colleges first arose in the nine
hundreds if not even in the late eighth
hundreds in northeastern Iran and he
said no no no no no we did not have a
happy time of this argument except I
have a lot of evidence and he had tenure
so you know so he was sort of edging me
out in this and eventually he wrote a
article for the second encyclopedia of
Islam the second edition about these
colleges and he said the colleges
originated in northeastern Iran in the
in the 10th century by citing evidence
that had been brought to his attention
somehow at an earlier stage but failing
to cite my work and then he said some
Iranian nationalists say that they're a
Persian invention but even though they
arise in Iran they're purely Arab he was
an Arab from Detroit and I never
realized when I was studying with him
that he was an Arab nationalist despite
the fact he looked exactly like him I
love de Nasser but the this sense of
what is Arab and what is Persian deeply
deeply affects the field to this day
the number of Erebus who learn you know
geckos HR and Persian who can count to
ten is miniscule the number of your
scholars of Iran who can read Arabic is
pretty substantial because of that is
the language in which all the earlier on
iam sources about Iranian history
written so you curtiss-wright the
earliest revere on you have to know
Arabic but if you're going to write a
history of Islam from a Arab point of
view you don't have to know anything
about Iran and then you have slanging
matches you know the Persian say the
Arabs are lizard eaters alright
what's wrong with lizard you know South
American prairie chicken that's another
and then the I knew chameleon being
marketed iguana being our market under
that label and then the the Arabs
respond that the Persians are defeat and
and of course Shiites and as Shiites
they believe in temporary marriage
because they are sex mad that's terrible
stuff but it affects the scholarship and
one of the effects what is that the
scholarship focuses on Syria and Arabia
that is the story of early Islam of the
story they're washed in Caleb's are the
story of the Umayyads and to the degree
that it deals with places to the east it
deals with Iraq and particularly with
the two big Garrison's that become major
cities in Iraq Kufa Basra and then at
the beginning of the Abbasid period city
of Baghdad these are the you know you
say well the real centers of Islam are
Kufa and Buster and Baghdad in Iraq and
then Damascus in particularly Damascus
in Syria
Kairo or hose ankle-foot stop in Egypt
and Mecca and Medinah and this is where
the culture of early Islam developed but
if you're an Iranian or if you are
looking at this from a rallying point of
view what you say is Iran was the center
of the Caliphate for from the time of
the fall of the Umayyads in 750 down
until let's say for 250 years the real
center of Islam was in Iran and not in
Iraq not in the sort of pseudo Iran
where the saw are the sassanids and the
Parthian 's and the ik eminence had had
their administrative headquarters but
rather up on the Iranian Plateau you
climb the mountains up on the Zagros
Mountains of separate Iraq from Iran and
you go on the plateau and that becomes
plateau becomes the center of the
Islamic community how do we know that
why should one suggest a thing other
than being some sort of corrupt Iranian
nationalist time I'm not you know I'm
kind of sort of Northern Illinois
nationalist but we don't have a dog in
this fight so what can I say the one
thing you can do is to look at where the
the geographical origin is of the people
who become prominent interpreters of
Islam the scholars the collectors of the
hadith of the Prophet the originators of
legal and philosophical theological
views where are these people born the
philosophers where do they come from
well I sure as hell don't come from
Egypt and they don't come from Syria if
you do a
a hard count on the basis of pretty
extensive quantity quantifiable material
you'll find that Egypt and Syria
together prior to the year 1200 never
produce more than 20% of the religious
elite of Islam as that elite comes to be
to leave traces in the in the
documentary record it's usually
something like 12 13 percent for Syria
and 4 5 percent for Egypt it is
astonishing how insignificant Egypt is
when you consider that that people today
think Cairo must been the great center
of Islam
it wasn't Baghdad was a great center but
a Kyra and the Egyptians were not
playing
much of a role in Islam the Syrians
slightly more but let us say from 850
until 11:15 or so Iran is producing
between say 35 and 50 percent of all of
the religious elite of the Muslim
community incidentally Spain is
producing you know like Oh point zero
one percent you know southern Pakistan
same thing I mean the game is all in
these two areas Iraq and Iran which
together are way over 50% with Iran
becoming more important than Iraq and
Egypt in Syria trailing far behind that
then changes by 1250 most of the
religious elite of the Muslim world are
either Egyptians or running or Egyptians
or Syrians you have a tremendous change
in the locusts the center of gravity of
Islamic culture and religious thought
and writing that takes place pretty much
in the 13th century but before that it's
really around and the question is why
why Iran they're not they don't speak
Arabic they all learn Arabic if they're
scholars they have to because the
language of Islam was Arabic the Persian
language does not really take shape in
Arabic script until until the nine
hundreds and even more the 1000s and
there remains to this day a great deal
of debate over where in the world we
first about why Iran does not learn to
speak Arabic as the basic language of
the country because middle Persian was
no more alien to the Arabic language
than the Egyptian spoken in Byzantine
times and yet Egypt becomes comply
completely Arabic speaking and Iran does
not so this question of why Iran becomes
Arabic speaking and then there's
question of the nature of the new
language the nature of the new language
is has two hallmarks first it is
exceedingly simple we know of eight to
ten middle Persian languages and
dialects that were spoken in Iran at the
time of the conquest and gradually they
all disappear or survive only as obscure
remnants in far distant valleys in
Tajikistan
things like that yell Kenobi for example
but by and large all of these middle
Persian languages disappear and they're
replaced by a single language that is
simpler than any of them
it has no case endings has no gender
it has a verb structure that is
phenomenally simple it has a vocabulary
that is simplified in various ways so
that's one characteristic the second
characteristic of this of this new
language which is not we have no
pre-islamic manifestation of this form
of Persian but the other hallmark of it
is that it's written in the Arabic
script I think about that you have a new
language that is understood by every /
every Iranian from Baghdad to Kabul no
matter what their own language is they
all more or less can understand this new
language because it is kind of a simple
distillation but the only way they can
understand it when it's written is if
they're Muslims because after the Arabic
script now my conclusion even though the
earliest evidence for this comes from
chance preservation of lines of poetry
my own belief is that this was a trade
language and the reason there was one
language was because for the first time
in history you started to have a high
volume of inter-regional and
intra-regional trade involving iranians
and that it specifically involved muslim
iranians so that putting it in the
Arabic language at a time when almost
everyone was a non-muslim
was a way of keeping a secret in the
same way that Jews are at many points in
history put their their records and
their correspondence in Hebrew
characters even if the language itself
is German or Arabic or Persian or
something they'll use Hebrew characters
Armenians done the same thing because
the alphabet is a form of code it's a
way of concealing the meaning because a
period when you don't have broad
literacy you don't you can't you know
you can't get rosetta stone for for
Persian meaning you don't you don't have
an easy way to learn it there are no
grammar books there are no dictionaries
and for the Arabic script you really
have to be a Muslim to know it so you
have a trade language that's
understandable everywhere in the Iranian
region from Baghdad to Central Asia
Baghdad to Afghanistan and it's specific
to to Muslims now it also shows up among
the Jews so that some of the earliest
manifestations of this new language are
in Judaea Persian suggesting that if
there is a change in the commercial
universe it was shared by the Jews but
it was dominated by by the Muslims so
when I wrote about this that was a final
conclusion I got to my god the language
shows that there was a commercial change
now I'm taking the opposite course I'm
saying let us start from the idea that
language shows that there was a a
burgeoning of Commerce and of
inter-regional and intra-regional travel
that brought merchants into contact with
each other differentially as Muslims
other words the
Muslim merchants had great contact with
one another and used the new language
whereas the zero Astri and merchants or
those o Astrium farmers or land holders
they stayed home they weren't part of
whatever was going on so now you're
looking to possible leave that iran is
becoming prominent not because of
anything special about its islam so much
of something that's happening in this
economy it's almost a truism that
Islamic history avoids ever talking
about the economy because we long we've
hope we see if the end-all sources but
now now you know the possibility that
maybe the reason
Iran and Iraq become important in these
say from 750 down to ten hundred or ten
fifty is because of something that's
happening in the economy that is tied to
Islam and it's something that's not
happening in Egypt in Syria so what
could be happening in one area that's
not happening another area that could be
tied to Islam it also worth noting that
under the previous Persian empires I've
mentioned this again and again the the
center of rule and administration and to
a large degree of commerce for the sauce
hoods the Parthian 's and the
accountants was in Iraq and it was tied
into the old tradition of Mesopotamian
trade but now you appear to have this
trade taking place on the Iranian
plateau now we at the time of the Arab
conquests it seems likely from the
scattered bits of information we have
that there probably were no cities
larger than five to eight thousand
people anywhere on the
and what we now call Iran maybe in the
southwest but elsewhere the cities were
sort of walled Garrison's where
villagers could take refuge if there was
raiding and where caravans could stop
when they were carrying goods to and
from China on the Silk Road but you
didn't have any metropolis there's very
little evidence that you had a bazaar
very little evidence that you that you
had um you know substantial trade except
the trade that goes across the Silk Road
the long-distance trade because the fact
matter was that Iran didn't produce
anything worth self-worth by it was an
agricultural land it had metal deposits
there were metallic things there were a
few items here and there but there was
no big product and perhaps more
importantly there was no possibility of
travel by water
so whatever trade there was had to be
overland because there were no rivers
and Overland trade is vastly more
expensive than waterborne trade so what
happened to the economy what I believe
happened and what I've written about is
that Iran experienced the same sort of
thing that the United States experienced
in the 18th century that Egypt
experienced in 19th century oh that
experienced a massive cotton boom and
that what transforms the economy of Iran
was the growth of cotton Egypt we think
of in later times as being a huge
producer of of cotton but there was no
cotton grown in ancient Egypt ancient
Egypt was a land of linen and all the
mummies were wrapped in linen not in
cotton
cotton is a late comer to to Egypt there
was some cotton grown in the Orontes
River Valley in Syria but not very much
the European words for cotton come in
from from Syria
there was no cotton grown in Europe of
course but cotton was not that common
the only part of the Arab world that
grew cotton any quantity was Yemen not
happens that many of the Arabs who were
shipped off to fight wars in Iran were
from Yemen so now you have a you know
group of Arabs they go off to fight wars
but the wars come to an end they have to
fit into the economy they're saying gee
we're in a country that has a really hot
summer a long growing season and we know
how to grow cotton which they've never
heard of we have almost no evidence that
cotton was was even known in Iran as
other than that than an import in the
pre-islamic period we know that in
Central Asia there was cotton grown but
that cotton was grown in river valleys
that you didn't have in Iran so you
couldn't easily transfer the economy
plus the words used for cotton in
Central Asia were all derived from
Sanskrit for the principal ones were
divided derived from Sanskrit showing
that the connections were with India
where cotton is a long time major
production item and not with Iran the
words used for cotton elsewhere in Iran
were not the Sanskrit words from Central
Asia so what happened what I believe
happened is that Arabs
and small numbers of converts to Islam
were faced with the issue of how do we
live here in Iran after the war this is
a country where the land is owned and
settled by the people who were there
when we conquered nothing in early
Islamic law or tradition indicates that
the Arabs were permitted to settle in
the land they could not simply displace
the previous owners say on the way the
English could displace the Indians in
this country so here you had these Arabs
they had money because they've been part
of the army they shared in the booty
they were on the payroll for the army
but they didn't have any land in a
country that was overwhelmingly
agricultural had almost no manufacturers
and you know what were they going to do
Islamic law states that if you bring
dead land under production you own the
land now I've talked about this issue of
ownership before what does ownership
really mean you know we've always
defined ownership in Western Civ as
ownership of land but they also have
ownership of animals annual ownership of
water in Iran the crucial thing appears
to be ownership of water
Iran has no shortage of land it's a huge
country except it's mostly a desert if
you can bring water to the desert you
fulfill the condition of bringing dead
land under production and you now own
the land but of course you own the water
first
but ownership of the water is very
particular in Iran because it does not
follow either the Egyptian practice of
using the flood on the Nile where you
have collective cultivation of the lands
that are flooded by the Nile nor does it
follow the Mesopotamian practice of
diverting river water from the Tigris
and Euphrates into canals and then
diverting water from the canals on the
fields where you have to have a
collective administration of the canals
and constant unrepeated upkeep of the
canals but rather Iran's water is either
winter snow and rain in which will you
know support crops in certain areas the
crops usually taking the form of wheat
and barley that are planted in November
and come up in March
winter wheat in other words winter
barley but there are no rivers so in the
spring the runoff will produce no
torrents of the sort you can find in San
Diego or to Los Angeles casually the
torrents are useless essentially because
it's just last for a week or so then the
river goes back down again but what Iran
does have because of winter rains and
snows is groundwater now they have a and
they have an old practice of groundwater
so here here you have the mountainside
and you have a layer of wet soil if you
dig into this soil here with the well
the wet and you get down this is
impervious rock down here so that water
doesn't go any farther seep in any
farther essentially your water is
flowing downhill and will end up in the
center of the country in some salt marsh
or salt pan the sort you have in the
Death Valley but if you dig down here
your well will fill with water well
that'll be called a mother well
so then you say well I want to have a
village here so I would like to have
water flow out of the ground here where
it can irrigate crops provide fresh
water for the village and then the
irrigate more cup more crops downstream
for the village so if I could have a
underground tunnel I would run like this
the water would flow out by gravity flow
and this tunnel is called a cannot the
technology was known in Iran there were
engineers who were specialists on how to
design these tunnels extremely demanding
both to design and to dig because you
have to dig a series of wells and then
connect them underground in order to
have light and oxygen for the diggers
and you have to start here because if
you started here you would all drown so
you're digging back upstream planning to
hit the water table up here someplace
I think that the cannot that they had
before Islam primarily were auxiliary
sources of water for communities that
had their basic water from rivers or
rainfall or Springs or something like
that what you get with Islam is a huge
boom in new villages watered exclusively
by canals
this can be substantiated in a perhaps
unconvincing way by a careful
quantitative study of place names that I
will not go into because it's a sort of
you know strange methodology that has
not gained universal approbation
these Heights which I've already bout it
in my book on cotton climate and camels
and early Islamic Iran once you have the
water flowing it's pulling my gravity
you don't have to lift it no this is no
well it doesn't require a shadow for a
sepia or any of these irrigating devices
you simply have a little stream it's
like an artificial spring that flows out
in the ground and you can use it to grow
crops in the middle of the desert you
cannot have a village before you have
the water because it's in the middle of
desert ok you can't have the tunnel
unless you have the money to pay for the
tunnel you can't have the tunnel or the
village unless you have people who will
do the digging and to apply at the crops
so in other words there is a very
substantial level of entrepreneurship
somebody else put up the money
someone has to designate the place
someone has to recruit the laborer
someone has to pay all these expenses
upfront this is a capital intensive
project well who better than these
Muslims who have their money from the
army because this is the way they can
become part of the agricultural economy
now the problem is that this is so
expensive that you're not going to grow
wheat and barley on this land
but then the wheat and barley is being
planted in November and coming up in
March and being harvested before the
heat of the summer and for cotton you
want to take advantage of the heat of
the summer so what you're doing is that
you're using the 12-month a year flow of
the water to supply the other
requirement for
growing other words a long hot growing
season plus abundant water so you grow
cotton the people who grew the cotton
were Muslims many of them were in sort
of the pioneering early stages of Islam
at least in Iran either as Arab
immigrants or as converts they were also
the primary sources of knowledge about
Islam so if you wanted to find out about
Islam you went to you know these guys
and you said tell it tell me about your
religion or maybe you went and you said
I like a job you know on your next
village and they said hey you know find
love to have you by the way you have to
be a Muslim because we don't want no
pagans here on our on our precious land
well it turns out that there are many
hadith of the Prophet that say that
Muslim men are not permitted to wear
silk specifically they are not permitted
to wear embroidered silk or brocade the
badge is the word in Arabic who can't
wear D badge and specific hadith will
say you know silk is for them in this
world and for us in the next world
because the Quran actually says that in
paradise you wear silk because silk is
really really nice if it feels good to
wear but it was for it was one of the
joys of paradise it wasn't for this
world for the believers and so you've
had eath that will say you know the
Prophet was given a piece of silk or a
silk garment so he gave it to Abu Bakr
and then Abu Bakr said why are you
giving me this garment
you won't wear it yourself either well I
thought maybe would give it to someone
else and that they knew the value of
silk they knew a nice silk class but
they wouldn't wear it according to these
stories these stories are all been
collected in Iran and there is saying
men can't wear can't wear silk what can
they wear well they should wear what the
car what the Prophet wore they should
wear plain white the Prophet liked plain
white not brocade not figured stuff thus
asana delete war you know amazingly
complex figured brocade of silk now you
have the Muslim elite are wearing plain
white cotton sometimes plain black
sometimes striped but not beyond stripes
not much of anything if you want to have
a luxury fabric for the Muslims in other
words if the ruler if the Caliph wants
to produce a luxury fabric its plain
white cotton with two inches of silk
embroidery and so you have hadith that
say God has prohibited the Muslims from
from wearing silk except the width of
two inches you know it's it's kind of
transparent that the same guys who were
growing the cotton were the pioneers of
Islam and we're telling people that if
you're going to become a Muslim you have
to wear what we are producing so as the
conversion curve proceeds the market for
their goods grows it's better than that
because Iraq can't grow cotton Iraq has
two tumultuous rivers that are so
destructive in the spring when they
carry the snowmelt down from Turkey the
Tigris and Euphrates that that you don't
do summer cropping in Iraq the first
place it's just beasts
hot secondly the rivers destroy the
irrigation works and so you spend the
summer trying to put them back together
and then you you really grow fall crops
so there was almost no cotton grown in
Iraq there were a couple of canals where
cotton could be grown
so instead Iraq imported all of its
cotton from Iran Baghdad became the
Manchester of the Iranian of the Iranian
cotton farmers just as Manchester was
the Manchester of the southern
plantation owners so you apparently had
immense quantities of cotton being grown
in Iran and sold to to Muslims but of
course had to be manufactured
now did you carry the raw cotton to
Baghdad and have it manufactured there
no you probably did not you probably did
the manufacturing in Iran and carry the
finished cloth around now that means
that you have to have manufacturers we
know almost nothing about it but this
becomes the great accelerator of urban
development in Iran that you now you
have an industrial product on a very
large scale that is being developed in
Muslim population centers in Iran by
let's say the year 850 or 900 it appears
that among the religious scholarly elite
in Iran 40% of the people who were
specialists on Islam were either grew
cotton or sold cotton cloth it was the
trade and there was nothing comparable
to it in that in in Iraq but it had
certain things it meant that you had now
you had Muslim Iranians traveling there
traveling to
sell cloth but they were also traveling
to collect hadith most of the hadith of
the Prophet are collected by Iranians in
Iran and Iraq not in Spain not in Yemen
but in Iraq and Iran these merchants
need to have communications they this is
where I think the new Persian language
comes from it is the language of a
pioneer as a no as a byproduct of the
growth of a manufacturing sector devoted
to cotton cloth the result is a mass of
one of the world's great periods of
urbanization between let us say 650 651
when the last Sossaman Shah is killed
and the year 1300 50 years of the the
largest cities of Iran grow from the let
us say 5 to 10,000 a person range to the
hundred two hundred thousand person
range
there's a massive urbanization for a
pre-modern
economy plus it it differs from almost
every comparable period of urbanization
you can think of in that it's not
accompanied by a gross increase in
population other words you have a
differential distribution of population
people are moving from the countryside
into these manufacturing cities and in
the process they are engaging in cotton
growing I think particularly near the
cities and this has two consequences one
is that it removes labor from the
countryside so that the remaining number
of farmers declines
and it removes acreage from from growing
grain so as the cities grow Iran becomes
hyper urbanized so that by the year 1000
Aaron has the largest cities in the
world not unnavigable water it has a
level of urbanization that would be
comparable perhaps to Renaissance Italy
or Flanders the height of its cotton
trade or of its wool trade but instead
of having a navigable water all the
trade is overland now this is important
because if you look at the history of
Italian cities during the Renaissance oh
and for that matter Flanders only know
less about that one of the things you
find is that they had to import food
they did not grow enough food to support
these hyper urbanized populations and
some people have argued that the black
death of 1348 is exacerbated by
malnutrition in the Italian countryside
because there simply weren't enough
farmers left to support the people in
the cities so one of the things we're
going to that you find in Iran it seems
is that when you get a crisis Iran isn't
producing enough food to support its
cities so after the year 1000 when the
crisis begins you start get families you
start to get epidemic disease and you
start to get urban unrest with violence
between factions and by the Year 1100
after a century of this you're getting
large-scale emigration of Iranians
leaving Iran and this emigration is
really important
despite the fact that Iranian ruling
dynasties had played a major role in
world history under the cabinets or the
Parthian Xin the sassanids and so forth
great these great empires none of them
had ever exported their language now for
the first time
Persian becomes a cultural language
outside of Iran it spreads to Turkey
especially Central Asia India it doesn't
spread because the Turks and the Indians
and the Central Asians as some scholars
have maintained decided they thought
Persian was a prettier language on their
own I can't believe anyone ever wrote
something like that but rather because
there were so many Iranians around who
were educated literate good writers and
they had an audience or other Iranians
because they had emigrated from a
country that was falling into a economic
catastrophe out of that economic and
catastrophe Syria and Egypt rise to
become the center of the Islamic world
and this is the second rise of the Arab
so if you talk about the Umayyads as the
arab kingdoms and its fall this is the
resurrection of the arabs that comes not
because of anything the arabs did
because in fact the people who are
ruling during this resurrection and out
arabs their turkish slave soldiers as
i'll talk about next time but but rather
because iran iran collapses and iraq
collapses and it's such an exciting
story that i can hardly wait until
thursday to continue to to tell you
about